are you hearing what i'm saying
no
outside of a fraternity fist fight
you're not necessary i mean listen if
i'm ever
in a dive bar and some hell's angels
start giving me a hard time because i
put benny in the jets on the jukebox and
was sipping a pink lady
you'd be my first call what do those dog
tags say anyway abercrombie and fitch
are you a bad boy
hey look i'm a bad boy
what will i do if i'm not on the x-men
maybe do a calendar shoot something
topless tasteful for the ladies i think
february maybe march one of the early
months nobody wants to be
december
they always put the worst guy on
december
the back of your head looks like johnny
depp's bush i feel like i'm letting
bigfoot into the woods skeleton
you see him yeah retractable
are you gonna heal from that you [ __ ]
you're just like the first act of the
bourne movies where he's just like what
is this what is this before any of the
cool parts what is this
what is this
repeating everything i love it
where am i from
and how do i get home
you